exactly a month ago today we shot a
market crash video and at the time i
knew the market was not in good shape
but the last 30 days based on a lot of
research and a lot of data that we've
looked at which i want to share with you
as bad as i thought it was it's a lot
worse now you get to do whatever you
want to do with this data dave ramsey
calls it fear points and there's a lot
of people getting scared and they're
excited about the markets nothing's
going to happen to the market it's going
to be all right because the inventor's
not taking a hit i'll give you data
you read the data free pdf choose
whatever you want you want to do with it
then make a decision for yourself
because when you look at three trillion
dollars of wealth being lost in
retirement in the first six months but
trillion in crypto and you know that
domino effect because the question
becomes is it too late can we do
anything about it when people stop
making money and their wealth goes away
they have less disposable income when
you have less disposable income there's
less spending when there's less spending
there's lower business profits lower
business profits leads to layoffs then
it's unemployment and it's foreclosures
and bankruptcies then divorce crime
drugs od alcohol protests riots back at
it again sounds scary but that's data
and by the way elon musk said recession
is part of the economical cycle that is
natural to go through it but there's
three p's that he talks about number one
is predict always stay multiple moves
ahead number two prepare get ready for
what's ahead and number three persevere
stand tall and find a way to make it
through and we're at the phase where you
got to be prepared and you got to
persevere you got to find a way to make
it through okay so a lot of this may
sound scary but i want you to put your
logical hat on set aside the emotional
head just go through these trends
process it together and then make a
decision what you want to do with
yourself and your business moving
forward having said that these are the
topics we're going to cover number one
mortgage industries how refi data is
affecting the industry the interest
rates how investors and builders are
backing out and kind of changing their
strategy active listings real estate
value construction layoffs freddie mac
deputy chief economist said something
very interesting foreclosures
consequences and the similarities
between now and 2008. so before we get
started let me give a quick shout out to
the sponsor of this video and that's
better help i'm a big believer of what
they do because a lot of people are in a
lot of pressure today and they don't
know who to talk to they don't know if
they talk to their spouse their dad
their parents their friends what better
help does in a very discreet way you're
able to deal and speak with a therapist
that you talk to one of them with the
challenges you're going through they got
20 000 plus options of therapists to go
through and if you don't like it you can
switch to somebody else you simply fill
out a question and within 48 hours they
match you with a therapist that suits
you for me
and back in 2007 2008 when i was going
through market crash and i have no clue
what's going to be happening especially
o70809 i start my own company there was
a guy who i was told was a therapist in
santa monica an hour and a half in
traffic i would drive from granada hills
i'd go to him he would sit there and
listen to what i was going through you
have no idea how helpful it was for me
the entrepreneur having somebody to sit
down with so if you're feeling alone
you've got a lot of stress in your life
give these guys a shot go to
betterhub.com forward slash
valuetainment you get 10 off your first
month one more time go to betterhelp.com
forward slash valuetainment you'll get
10 off your first month so let's get
right into it first thing i want to look
at is mortgage refunds and how investors
and builders are changing their approach
now when you think about the real estate
industry you have loan officers you have
realtors you have escrow title appraisal
all those guys but i want to focus on
loan officers what a loan officer does
is when you're buying a house that
you're buying a million dollar house you
need to get a million dollar loan
approved so the realtor can show you the
homes you go to a loan officer the loan
officer comes back and gets you the loan
for a million dollars and he'll say 3.8
percent 5.4 percent the loan officer
makes money in a couple different ways
one is
new homeowners
getting a loan from a loan officer or an
existing homeowner who is wanting to
refinance their house for lower interest
rates for example you bought a million
dollar house five years ago at six
percent i'm just making up the number i
call you i'm the loan officer i call you
a year later and i say hey interest
rates have dropped from six percent to
four point five five percent i'd love to
help you save some money on your payment
i can lower your payment from six
thousand dollars a month to five
thousand dollars a month oh my god
that's great let's refinance that's
refinance the loan officer makes roughly
two percent on that loan if the loan is
at that time say a million dollars two
percent twenty thousand dollars he's at
fifty percent he makes ten grand that's
the loan officer now watch what's been
happening with applications in the
refund market number one
mortgage application volume was 52.7
lower
last week compared to the same period
one year ago according to mortgage
bankers association now that's a
mortgage application which means i may
be buying a house and i want a loan for
a new mortgage of a house i'm buying but
watch refi
applications for refunds on existing
mortgage dropped 75 from a year ago
according to the mba's refinance
mortgage application index according to
aei housing center which tracks mortgage
applications by the number of rate logs
no cash refis have collapsed you ready
by
93
from a year ago that's 93
most of the loan officers 80 of their
income was on refi the last few years
the refi business is gone which means
that these guys were making 50 grand a
month now they're making roughly 10
grand a month if they were making 20
grand a month now they're making roughly
4 000 a month that's a very big
difference so now if you're somebody
that's saying pat i'm not in the real
estate world i'm not good with math what
does this really mean with interest
rates let me just simplify it for you if
you bought a half a million dollar house
let's just say your loan is 500 000 and
you bought it two years ago and you got
a nice three percent rate your payment
would be roughly two thousand one
hundred and eight dollars now
if you buy a house which roughly today
the rate's around six percent the same
five hundred thousand dollar loan at six
percent is two thousand nine hundred and
ninety seven dollars that's nearly nine
hundred dollars higher now if you were
to buy the same five hundred thousand
dollar loan at nine percent watch what
happens here the payment becomes four
thousand twenty three dollars it doubles
in payment from three percent same loan
amount
same house everything's the same one was
three percent it was twenty one hundred
dollars a month the other one is nine
percent it's four thousand dollars a
month how many americans can go from
twenty one hundred dollars a month to
four thousand dollars a month not many
that's interest rates so now some people
in the real estate world you may be
watching the same pack give me a break
it's not gonna go to nine percent it's
not going to go to 12 it's not going to
go to 15 okay fair maybe you're right
but
musk said prepare and i'm advising you
to be prepared so you can persevere so
let's say what if it goes to nine
percent i think it's gonna go to ten
percent i think it may even go higher
than ten percent but i think it's gonna
touch ten percent let's take a look at
the history of interest rates if you
look at this chart from 1970 till today
today it shows around 5.7 interest rate
if you go back a couple years you'll see
three percent 2.8 percent you see how
low it is right there now if you go back
20 years ago you'll see it was at 5.8
percent here's a crazy thing if you go
back around 2008 2007 and go all the way
back from 1970 till around 2007 2008
rates were never below 5.7
if you gradually move back you'll see it
go to six percent seven percent eight
percent nine percent 10 11
18 and a half percent during jimmy
carter era so you saw this i'm giving
you history i'm not selling you a loan
i'm not selling you to sell your house i
don't benefit from you doing anything
with your house i'm not in that business
i'm giving you stats here's a part you
have to be very careful with go to 81
when jimmy carter was president and it
was hyperinflation everybody was like oh
my gosh what's going on cd rates were at
14 and a half percent
what did we do back then
that caused rates to go this high
versus today
what we did back then was it as ugly
yesterday was it a big pandemic back
then no
today
printing money after printing money
after printing money after keeping rates
solo after all these things happening
we have fed the economy with so much
fake success
that it's about to pay price for it
meaning
be prepared that it could go that high
but definitely be prepared that it could
touch ten percent if and if it does my
example of five hundred thousand dollars
at three six nine percent you got to do
the math that are on ten percent here's
what this means
a 500 000 loan is probably going to be a
250 000 loan five years right now at
nine percent which means the value of
property could drop 30 40 50 in certain
areas not saying it's going to happen
just be prepared that it could now when
it comes down to builders a recent
article from bloomberg said the
following data builders are slashing
their prices on new homes at an
unbelievable rate as the market cools
and prices drop at the fastest pace
ready since 2006. austin texas nashville
new construction offering with price
cuts has quadrupled from a year earlier
phoenix tripled tampa region doubled so
now i want you to take a look at this
chart and kind of explain to you why
this matters so much when it comes down
to builders you're seeing this chart
that says one million homes and at the
top it's a single family building
backlog look at the difference with the
blue which is single family homes under
construction
permitted skyrocketing that's inventory
and the orange is mortgage purchase
demand this is from the u.s census
bureau so if if we happen more
builders are building areas that is not
bought by anybody but mortgage is
dropping that's when inventory goes up
when inventory goes up prices goes down
this is not a good sign to look at when
it comes on to a value of homes staying
stable so the next thing to take a look
at is active listings which dave ramsey
who said you know the sphere porn all
the stuff that he says it's just not a
big deal maybe a little bit it's not
going to happen nothing over five years
which by the way five years he may be
right that nothing's really gonna happen
over five years but we're talking today
okay we're talking today when hey i want
to buy a house right now you may want to
wait another year until you buy a house
just watch this data here and you make a
decision for yourself so this is from
realtor.com
show in active listings and you'll see
the different colors represent different
years 2017 18 19 20 21 22. i want you to
focus on 2022 all the way at the bottom
which is yellow you'll see the active
listings in january goes down if it goes
down property value goes higher because
there is less inventory for you to buy a
house for example if i make an offer on
a house here and i'm saying i want to
buy a house that's close to this
schooling because i want to send my kids
to this private school and my realtor
says there's only two houses in this
market with a swimming pool i don't have
a lot of options there's only two homes
if there was 50 i can negotiate and said
if you don't give it to me at this price
i'll go over there but if it's only two
they're going to get 50 offers because
50 people are fighting to get that one
house the seller's in charge but if
listing was 50 the buyer is in charge
make sense so look at the numbers
january to february inventory goes down
this is good for sellers february to
march pretty much unchanged good for
sellers march to april goes up a little
bit better for buyers look at april to
may
goes up look at me to june goes up 18.7
now that's only two months
if this chart the number two follows
this one it's very important if the
active listing keeps going higher and
higher and higher and builders have a
bunch of place that's not occupied and
that goes higher and higher and higher
and the amount of mortgage applications
goes lower and lower and lower you don't
need to be a genius to know you have to
drop the value of your house to sell it
it's just what's going to happen that's
pure basic economy supply and demand
this is why one of the most important
data to look at is active listing that
tells a story so that real estate value
obviously in the last two years has gone
up not 10 not 15 not 20 percent it's
gone up 40.4 percent some areas even
more than 40.4 but across the board 40.4
which is great it's gone up so people
are making money if you own a house you
build a lot of equity for yourself but
here's a challenge if that's going up
what else has gone up construction's
gone up steel's gone up materials gone
up energy's gone up furniture has gone
up concrete's gone up transportation's
gone up soft wood lumber's gone up price
of freight has gone up 26 percent price
of deep sea transportation freight is up
35
so that's all good for the economy but
what happens now when inventory goes up
and people are no longer buying at the
pace that they were what's going to
happen to that 14 40.4 could it go back
down to zero if it goes back down 40
percent that's what it's what it was
worth two years ago so that's pretty
realistic but what if it goes down 60
what else takes a hit steel furniture
construction all of those industries
also take a hit this is why it's all
intertwined but let me continue remember
at the earth at the beginning when we
talked about the fact that less
disposable income leads to less spending
lower business profits layoffs
unemployment foreclosure bankruptcies
divorce crime drugs or the alcohol
protest riots okay what does this lead
to layoffs
there's layoffs everywhere compass
who dave i love compass i've done
business with compass for many many
years they're great
compass is letting go ten percent of
their self compasses like the you know
the high-end community realtors your
workout companies is very prestigious
they're letting go of ten percent okay
redfin announced they're laying off a
ton of people chase they're laying off
just a thousand loan officers and then
you're seeing layoffs in all these other
industries but this is what
freddie mac's deputy chief economist len
kiefer said last week tweeted about this
he said the u.s housing market is at the
beginning stages of the most significant
contraction in activity since 2006. by
the way keep in mind he doesn't get paid
to do this he's in the industry so
freddie mac knows something about this
because they've been through this before
but they're also saying it's going to be
worse than 2006 which the last one i'm
going to share with you in this topic is
foreclosures why foreclosures this early
aren't foreclosures are supposed to
happen six months from now maybe next
year
what would you say is the increasing
percentage of foreclosures that we have
in 2022 compared to last year same time
what do you think the increase is 20
more foreclosures 40 more foreclosures
60 more foreclosures
wow it's not going to be 100 right you
ready
we have 700 more foreclosures this year
same time than we did last year let me
say that one more time
700
23
204 foreclosures according to the
database management company att om data
solutions that's 700
and it's just getting started okay
these are the kind of things when you
watch big short did you notice how cocky
and arrogant everybody was lehman's
going out of business you're crazy one
was going out and they've never happened
or one was a 300 with aig oh [ __ ] there
were
merrill lynch countrywide new century
you're out of your mind that'll never
happen and then everybody said holy [ __ ]
it's happening so i'm not telling you
it's going to happen all i'm telling you
is history says
if it repeats itself it's happening
except it may be uglier because we
printed way more money now this next
data simulators of all 2008 versus today
in 2008 okay the average worker say made
80 000 a year whatever the number is
the house prices at the time were eight
times the average workers earnings eight
times eighty is what six hundred forty
thousand dollars right you know what the
number is today
eight and a half times
so if in 2008 was eight times the
average american's like i can't afford
to buy that big of a house what are you
talking about it's eight times my income
it's crazy
don't worry it's eight and a half today
okay which means it's worse than what it
was in oh wait which means what it's got
to come back down to around three or
four times which is the number
okay it's either income is going to go
up which it ain't going to go up because
there's layoffs whereas the price of
real estate is going to come down so
again
if you're watching fear porn like dave
ramsey says i'm giving you stats go chop
these data up and say it's a bunch of
crack or whatever but give your argument
this is data telling you eight and a
half times today versus what it was in
2008. so everything we talked about so
far is real estate related right it's
all tied to real estate but what about
crypto all these people that became
crypto millionaires 80 000 wiped out 80
000 crypto millionaires wiped out what
do you think they were buying nice homes
nice cars nice watches
wiped out luxury watches exotic rolexes
patek felipe they're taking a massive
hit exotic car's taking a massive hit
all the tech stocks nasdaq is down smp
is down 19 for you nasdaq can sound 28
for the year it doesn't matter where you
look at everything's taking a hit and
everything's intertwined so when you're
looking at this data and you're asking
yourself how bad can it be michael bury
from the big short said the following he
said as i said about 2008 it is like
watching a plane crash it hurts it's not
fun and i'm not smiling he also
predicted that the next crash will dwarf
the 2008 bus which sparked a global
financial crisis okay so now that you've
put your logical hat on and you got a
lot of data let's take that off put the
emotional hat on because we gotta now
move you gotta move you gotta take some
action we'll give you the pdf here in a
second but stick around there's a few
things i want you to be thinking about
number one i said this back in 2009 2010
when i had a lot of money in the bank
cash and denver posted an article on me
saying why are you living in a house and
you're renting i said why do i why
should i buy a house well isn't that the
american dream i said absolutely not
american dream is not home ownership
american dream is equity
in businesses
entrepreneurship
side hustles you know being part of a
startup getting a piece of that company
that company go sells it goes public
that's the american dream then you make
the money there and then you can buy a
house if you choose to the stress has
been so much about the american dream we
have to shift so a lot of people are
looking at renting and by the way the
plus minus for renting right now it's
850 more makes sense to rent than it is
to buy it's more expensive to buy today
than it is to rent to own to rent so
that's one part now again if you're in
real estate you're not gonna like what
i'm talking about but i've been straight
up with you since the day i started
value team so that's number one number
two side hustle if you're making a
million now you're making 200 you got to
do something on the side if you're
making 200 you're making 50 now you got
to do something on the side if you're
fully unemployed you don't have a job go
learn new skill set and get a side
hustle for yourself there's never been
more important than how to do that
collaboration find the right
partnerships
save money today get some cash things
are going to be discounted even more my
prediction i may be wrong but i'm
telling you what i'm doing things are
going to be discounted even more i
believe the next 6 12 18 months don't
try to time it perfectly you just want
to be able to get it as low as possible
even though you're not going to hit the
to get things you purchase at the rock
bottom
very few people get that lucky but even
if you get it 20 of rock bottom or 10
above rock bottom you're gonna be fine
things are going to be discounted over
the next six 12 18 months just an hour
before i shot this video i got a tweet
from a guy that's a valuetainer sending
me pictures of a bunch of watches that
are you know million for watch or rafael
nadal he's selling this next one here
for a hundred and you know thirty two
thousand dollars this next one is sixty
eight thousand dollars he sent me all
this stuff with watches all of these
guys are gonna be discounted 50 more
percent the next six or 12 months
because people are not gonna have a
choice they need cash and last but not
least as painful as it is it's time to
recreate yourself and start kind of
doing your own research don't wait for
me to do it go study for yourself i did
a zoom with a bunch of ceos yesterday 83
of them were on
ceos that are part of our consulting
firm you know what every one of them i
taught i went 15 minutes showing them
how to research anything within their
industry said here's how you research go
spend an entire day not an hour not 30
minutes winging it spend an entire day
away from everybody research the history
of your industry to learn what kind of
right pivots to make so now having said
that i owe you this pdf if you want this
pdf click over here to get the entire
thing all the notes all the links
everything we talked about and if you
never got a chance to watch the market
crash video somebody share this video
with you because you're in real estate
you may want to watch the market crash
video as well click on that link here to
watch that have a great day everybody
take care future looks bright
[Music]